[Musique]
alfredo j'ai voulu que tu viennes dans
la première émission de ban minuit parce
que je suis un fanatique boxé depuis le
début depuis l'épée de bois depuis va
péronne je crois que comédie policière a
été un grand moment à shalio comme ça
non avec le décor qui s'ouvrait la
maison qui s'ouvrait j'ai vu luxe au
palace dépit ya dix ans à peine de coeur
d'une chatte anglaise alors aujourd'hui
il ya cette pièce de marivaux qui est
tout à fait étonnante parce que faire
jouer des gens qui sont habillés comme
c'est grotesque comme les singeries du
18e qui joue marivaux avec l'accent
argentin
c'est quand même un pari incroyable dont
il ya des gens qui vont voir ça il avait
ce jeune qui respecte tous écrits il ya
quelqu'un qui écrit à istres à la
culture en inde en interdire notre pièce
parce qu il trouvait que ça ait porté
tort à marivan et moi je craque et non
que marivaux doit bien se réjouir de
cette version parce que là ces pièces
puce ont été créés par des comédiens
italiens sont d'ailleurs des comédiens
comme nous qui parlait avec un fort
accent et il aimait ça va ce qu'il
disait et il parlait le texte plus
lentement ce qui donnait aussi un champ
dans son phrasé différents et qui sale
et des poudres est salée de coiffer et
puis harlequins les toute façon on avait
une masse qu à masquer pas lui qui
rappelle les échanges et les toute façon
dans les pièces de marivaux
qu'aujourd'hui on considère les pièces
très formel très structuré très belle
d'un point de vue psychologique quand
même aller qu'en fait c'est des
pirouettes
alors si tu veux je crois que c'est sans
j'apporte l'animalité la force
nécessaire à ce texte et qui parfois se
sont un peu endormi peu spécieux appelé
à brûler sa poudre et mais c'était juste
de prétexte que hyndman et aux courriels
10 échoué line naturellement gelé comme
si vous ne lui donnez
sans donner de l'importance avec une
force naturelle et je crois que c'est
animant par le sort des mages il donne
cette force au texte et se réjouit à
beaucoup de spectateurs il ya ceux qui
trouvent ça peut-être mais c'est bien de
voir cette nuit tu trouvais ça
formidable
oui aujourd'hui c'est la générale
aujourd'hui oui ça s'est passé
formidablement bien
et puis tu sais que c'était la pièce qu
avec laquelle moi j'ai fait mon retour
en argentine depuis huit ans d'absence
voilà moi à cause de toi ou pas ça toi
plutôt j'ai eu envie d'aller en
argentine alors raconte-moi le voyage
commence à cet aspect parce qu'elle 20
ans tout est parti de wade initiale
c'est à dire que pour moi c'était assez
particulier puisque et en même temps on
a fait un film a été la libération alors
à la fois cette réalité et fiction
mélanger c'est une fiction qui m'a
permis en un temps de découvrir toute
une partie de mon pays que j'ai
peut-être et je n'aurais pas osé toucher
107 caméra derrière moi alors il ya eu
des choses drôles de choses mandole les
choses fortes mais eh bien non
pour moi j'ai passé déjà les mêmes teint
de vie ici que là-bas
l'argentine vit un peu aujourd'hui et
qui sont passés derrière elle avec son
sa grande époque derrière elle
avant de regarder le sujet extrait du
film que tu as fait avec jean-pierre
thibaudat été délibération pour la 7
je voudrais justement de poser cette
question est ce qu'aujourd'hui tu vas
pas le sentiment qu'avec l'arrivée d'un
pouvoir politique dillon équilibré avec
alphonsine et le changement de capital
est ce que tu crois pas que l'argentine
est en train de de partir finalement
dans une nouvelle direction est ce que
le changement le fait que vielles demain
carmen ne patagonia devienne une
nouvelle capitale pour l'argentine que
l'argentine se décide à conquérir le le
le sud est ce que c'est pas finalement
un nouveau départ ou est ce que toi ça
te rend triste finalement non non
c'était le problème maintenant c'est que
on les voit mal d'alcool chine vient
d'être touché
élections législatives comme tu le sais
et le péronisme arrêt pris une peinture
oise qui me semblait logique puisque
c'est une force très importante du pays
et mais il faudrait comme peut-être ici
aussi que ceux des forces et se met
ensemble travailler pour le pays il est
en pole en profondeur ce qui implique et
et non darwin est un pays qui a souffert
commissaires dans les dernières années
je crois que c'était dit le retard sur
le pays je ne sais pas si tout de suite
mais j'ai toujours espoir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou